anyways I just want to say that I'm I
can't say enough how delighted I
to be here I I do remember Perry when
this was a gleam in your eye you know
and I am just in awe of the work that's
been done these past ten years in
bringing together a community that's
truly has been a need for understanding
compassion and effective ways out of
their health so we're all part of that
today so I'm really really glad to be
here so let's see how this works okay
there we go
oh yes I have to tell you I have to
disclose all my conflicts of interests
and other disclosures so first of all I
do work for I do I am a consultant for
behavioral tech which is owned by the
Linehan Institute I do teach with Marsha
and do work on implementation of
dialectical behavior therapy I have some
other things disclosed first of all I'm
talking about pharmacology appointments
today sometimes people ask me about
drugs even though that's not what I want
to talk about is which drugs you use so
I just might need to make sure you know
that any medication there is no
medication approved for borderline
personality disorder so if I discuss a
medication it will be off-label I have
some other things to disclose so you
might as well get these off the table
right away I am 53 and if you don't know
about the concept of a sacrifice cake
you should talk to my teenage boys
apparently when you're this old you put
all the candles on the cake the cake is
unedible so you have to have a second
cake
and then last month I bought a cigar for
my 15 year old he's right there and it
was he was being taught how to smoke
cigars by a friend of mine and he did
throw up a couple other things I have a
13 year old who I apparently annoy and
although I was Minnesota psychiatrist of
the year what I really wish is that I
could be the Dairy Queen Princess K of
the Milky Way at the state fair because
she gets her her face done in a butter
bust every year and honest to god if you
go to the State Fair in Minnesota but
you can't believe it you can watch the
sculptures carving the butter bus of
Princess Kay and her maidens of Honor in
a refrigerated room that's all glass so
you could walk around and watch them so
I don't know maybe someday okay it's
good to get that off my chest you know
so there was three things that we were
going to talk about today kind of just
to remind you of what this what the
objectives were is I'm trying I was
trying to figure out how to describe the
therapeutic tools that I use within the
midst of delivering psycho
pharmacotherapy in other words I'm
prescribing medications but what I'm
doing in it is how I go about it with
the patient and how do I pull out
functional behavior and at the end of it
a better relationship between me and the
patient and a more likely chance that
what we're doing is going to help so I
thought I'd go about it by by Framing
pharmacotherapy in what we call the
functions of treatment in DBT and then
talk a little bit about how I organize
the session in all behavior therapies we
use target hierarchies and finally to
try to weave in a little bit about the
principles of the treatment that are
used between me and the patient you know
it's a 524 page treatment manual and I
have less than an hour so it was a
little bit of a challenge I know some of
you are DBT practitioners some of you or
not so I'll do my best to convey the
sense of what I do in these appointments
with my patient the other comment I want
to make is to refer back to what dr.
sledge said
I have to tell you the only reason I do
DBT was very practical I've been in
public health my entire life my whole
career has been devoted to public health
in 1994 the state of Minnesota
Department of Human Services hired me to
help to figure out how to help them with
all these individuals with borderline
personality disorder who were getting
committed against their will into state
institutions and and I said I like a
challenge
and this is a group of individuals that
I was interested in and so in 94 I did
as a public health physician I did what
I thought a public health physician
should do is find out is there any data
of anything that works and in 1994 the
only randomized control trial of a
treatment that seemed to be effective
was dialectical behavior therapy I
didn't know what the word dialectical
meant I'm afraid to say I'm sure
everybody Gail knew what it meant I
trained in Oklahoma what could I say
you know I had been trained by analysts
in five years of psychodynamic
psychoanalytic supervision so I didn't
know anything about behavior therapy but
what I knew was this this article said
that this worked and I was in public
health so do you see how I ended up
there I think the spirit I want to say
is is how thrilling it is to me that
individuals and families have choices of
things that if something doesn't work
you can try a different approach and
that clinicians do because it turns out
clinicians do treatments effectively
when they like the treatment they're
doing so more power to us I mean I
really mean that one last thing about
what I want to say here is that not only
am i thrilled to be here but one of my
patients donated his diary card for
y'all today and it's in the extra
handouts and he gave me permission to
use his first name his name is Adam but
he said you have to read you a statement
so I wrote this down in our last session
and Adam is both someone I do
pharmacotherapy with and I'm as
individual DBT therapist and he said
okay tell them this is from one of your
students now isn't that sweet
I miss therapists he thinks of me as his
teacher I just was like I mean my little
heart just went like this
he says that he wants you to know that
he's been working hard in DBT and it's
been a roller coaster for him but he
does not give up and he wants everybody
to know they should never give out give
up he says I want to give a shout out to
all the people in the room who have
borderline personality disorder remember
every day is a new day try to stay in
the moment at least one time each day
and remember you can do that you can do
this so that's Adam and he says he
wishes he could be here too so thank you
Adam
all right says in dialectical behavior
therapy the treatments overarching goal
is always to get the person to the life
that makes life worth living for them
everything else is about sorting things
out and getting either things reduced
that get in the way of that or
aspects and behaviors about within
yourself as well as in the people you
live with that promote you getting there
so so with that in mind pharmacotherapy
is a piece of a clinical tool within
that alright so so the other thing that
I like to remember too is that there
really are three ways biological
organisms change and so I'm trying to
help someone get from the hell that
they're in to out of hell and beyond you
know there's three ways I can see that
they can do that one of them is
something that I don't necessarily have
control over which is maturation or
development you know we start out like
this and then we end up here and then we
end up spending money with
dermatologists and stuff but that's not
great that goes with number three you
can do chemical alteration or direct
manipulation of biological systems which
is where the pharmacotherapy lives and
then where all the other interactions
that I do even if I'm only being the
pharmaco therapist and not the primary
therapist is I know that we can change
through experience which is otherwise
known as learning and is the idea of
harnessing the principles of learning
that are occurring all the time it's
like I say to people you know the Sun is
always shining right but if you actually
understand how it shines you can build
solar voltaic cells and direct the
energy so it's the same thing with
learning and how we interact with
each other.what strengthens certain
behaviors what gets us to stop other
things those principles are working
whether we've identified them or not so
for me learning to be a behavior
therapist has helped me just get more
precise and harnessing what's already
happening all the time the Sun is always
shining how do I turn it into a laser
beam it's kind of that sort of the
experience to me so that's part of what
I'm going to talk about as we go through
this okay now in dialectical behavior
therapy if you're not familiar with it
one of the ways it frames the treatment
is that you have to look at what is
treatment s'posed to do now there is the
functions meaning what's supposed to
happen here what's the purpose of this
you know the overall function is to help
the person get a life worth living but
to do that what do you have to do to get
there and so the framework of it
includes these five functions so we look
at the fact that a person if they're in
hell are disordered are suffering
terribly from the intensity of their
emotions and how to manage them then we
have to have something that is able to
get them to increase their capabilities
to increase new learning the other thing
is something that we have to have things
in there that help motivate them to try
these new things to not give up like
Adam says don't give up don't ever give
up and Adam works his butt off I can
tell you this he does not give up so we
have to have treatment modalities that
do that the other thing is we know that
what you learn in the room with me or
with your teacher will not translate out
to the real world or out to your world
where it matters unless we help you
figure out how to get it there so we
talked about generalization the next
thing is in DBT all DBT clinicians
realize that they have to be better at
what they do that they need to be able
to be effective to practice with
fidelity and so we have to have ways to
do that OOP sorry
I keep moving around but I'm not moving
far enough to put that thing on my body
this thingy okay maybe I will and
finally structuring the environment how
do we get people to live in environments
that actually help them as opposed to
environments that may be contributing to
their disorder so those are we've got to
figure out a way to do that well I'm
going to show you where pharmacotherapy
lies with that so pharmacotherapy is
lays in this function here I want to use
if I'm going to use medications with you
I want to be sure that the medications
I'm using are helping you acquire new
behaviors new learning and helping you
integrate and God forbid that the
medicines I give you are actually
interfering with you learning as many do
so you see how I see how I'm thinking
about it as I do that with my patients
and so we talked about modalities and
you can see on here pharmacotherapy I
guess I might pointer I know there's a
pointer in this is all this equipment Oh
God
which one of these is the pointer the
green one yeah look at that cool all
right
even I could figure that out so what we
mean by this is if this is the function
what it's supposed to do what do we what
how do we engaged in doing it so I've
got pharmacotherapy there so I just
wanted to frame this in there you a lot
of people who know about DBT everybody
gets some sort of skills class or skills
training which is also for enhancing
capabilities but this is where I'm
acting when I'm prescribing medications
all right
the other thing that I just want to
point out is enhancing therapists
capabilities and motivation oops
Oh what did that do cool all right
here's this right here if you're a DBT
practicing pharmaco therapist you're
also on a DBT consultation team so in
other words in that 524 page manual
there's all kinds of strategies and
principles for a clinician to use to be
effective with the individual they're
trying to help and so even if I'm in a
30-minute Medicaid
meeting I'm still bringing all of those
to bear and to be good at doing that I
depend on getting consultation from team
members to make me that much better so
those are the ways that you're gonna see
a pharmacotherapies like me practicing
on a DAT team and this is just a
reminder if you don't know that and this
is also unusual sometimes for some
physicians the primary therapist works
with the patient to run the case and
everybody else on the team works for
them and the patient so if I'm not the
individual therapist as the prescriber
on the team I defer to the primary
therapist in terms the overall case
formulation the hierarchal they're
working on what they're targeting and I
don't and it's it's tricky because in
psychiatry even with liability issues
and things like that there's all who's
in charge of the case you know that's
legalistic things phenomenologically I
work for the primary therapist and the
patient but the primary therapist is in
charge and so that's also a principle
that I made touch on in terms of how you
manage some of the things that happen in
a pharmacotherapy session all right okay
now this is this is we're getting to
actually what what do you do in the
sessions and this is really important is
there is a hierarchy of behavioral
groupings that I pay attention to in a
session and that some become more
important than others in terms of if
they're happening I address them first
and it's very interesting how that plays
out so for those of you don't know I'm
first going to go ahead and show you the
standard hierarchy for the primary
therapists and in any individual therapy
session so this is just in an individual
therapy session the therapist is paying
attention in this order there's been any
life threatening behaviors they address
those above any therapy interfering
behaviors above quality of life so if
someone's cut themselves or had a
suicide attempt that week that takes
over the fact that they didn't do their
homework for skills class if this is
okay and they didn't do their homework
for skills class but the therapist makes
sure they touch on that and then quality
of life is all those other things that
make you miserable the PTSD symptoms the
drug abuse though everything else and in
that you increase skills now if you
switch over to the pharmacotherapy
session it changes because remember I've
got a primary therapist dealing with
those things so what happens in the
office with me is slightly different
obviously if something is going to
destroy that meeting I've got to take
care of it we'll talk about each of
these but then I actually in this order
decrease symptoms known to effectively
manage I'm actually constantly looking
at what is it that you say you're
suffering from and will these meds do it
and then the next thing is I'm looking
at health related things and then the
last thing is actually pharmacotherapy
interfering which some fees could be
counterintuitive in the sense that you
think well if they're not taking their
meds that's the first thing you're all
over I'll have to tell you this really
works you almost never have this by the
time you're done doing these and I just
have to say Charlie Swensons here and
charlie is really the person that I
spend a lot of time talking to and
learning these targets so I just want to
make sure everybody knows that being one
of the other psychiatrist to practice
this you know you've spent a lot of time
thinking about this and as as Marsha and
I'll have to say it's fascinating to me
how little work I do on this because of
how I'm doing that so that's an
important piece of this let me go over
each one of these all right here's what
I want to say about targeting the reason
we use a hierarchy of behavioral targets
is you have an individual borderline
personality sorter all the parts are
there they're all over the place some of
them you need some of them you don't
right how are you gonna frickin organize
this so that they can drive a car out of
hell okay this is the hell right and you
got to make a car and get out and you
know what the thing is is people
mentioned this morning I am privileged
by being affirmed that there
to treat people who there is no way even
standing on their heads that they can
meet the criteria for borderline
personality sir anymore
and I get to still see them because
every three months or no we need to
check their antidepressant oh my god
it's such a privilege such a privilege
so I just wanted to say that this is
what we're taking this and we're gonna
build a car alright so let's talk about
the first thing things that are likely
to destroy therapy meaning the
pharmacotherapy session is obviously if
someone's about to kill themselves
medications don't work in dead people so
it's not like you're not going to deal
with that what's interesting about that
if you're working on a DBT team is that
even if you have someone where you're
doing a risk assessment and management
protocol because you have to right there
in the moment if they have a primary
therapist the principal is I'm trying to
get them back to that primary therapist
to really help manage the details so for
example I'm thinking I'm going to try to
put in examples from patients here I was
thinking about this as I was looking
about it is I have a patient who I'll
call MK who has terrible bipolar
disorder dissociative identity disorder
post-traumatic stress disorder and
borderline personality sort on an eating
disorder and and you hear all that you
go my goodness this woman has gone from
80 pounds curled up in a psych ward to
married finished college have the job of
her dreams her husband's her best
friends so keep this in mind as you're
hearing this okay and and very severe
but of her bipolar disorder is really
hard to manage and so for example last a
year ago I had her in my office and she
didn't sleep at all the night before
she'd associated and was driving around
and found herself in parks you know that
aren't too good to be at at 3 in the
morning so she hasn't slept at all she's
got you know things to cut herself with
in the car as well as a bunch of aspirin
to take at the same time and she's
psychotic she's in a total bipolar mixed
state
she's completely psychotic she wants to
be dead she's in my office obviously I
have to deal with that right now right
you know so as I'm doing the risk
assessment management protocol she also
has to have
case manager there and luckily we can
get her primary therapist on the phone
so the team of us her primary therapist
running the show on the speakerphone we
make it we work with her get something
set up and she and the case manager are
good to go to unfortunately we had to
put it in the hospital but it was all
done with that primary therapist you see
what I mean it wasn't just me deciding
something by myself that was really
important and that's and that's how I've
worked with them kay and she's very
connected to all of us on the team so
that's an example but but that's not the
main thing we do in pharmacotherapy it's
just obviously you can't get anywhere
you know the other things I think of is
people like forging your scripts or
things that are just gonna say look I
just we got it this has gotta stop
I haven't had that problem but I do know
people do or people getting aggressive
and I do have a patient who has severe
developmental disorder who has tried to
clobber me a couple times but she's a
sweetheart we've dealt with that okay
she is she's actually what she and I
figure because she's on the autism
spectrum we actually figured out that no
one had ever showed her how to use
FaceTime on the iPad so now we FaceTime
even if I'm sitting downstairs in the
office at her group home it's great and
she like talks and talks and talks so
we're good we're good
okay so here's where the first step
really starts is is decreasing the
specific symptoms known to be affected
by medicines and this is where precision
becomes important and really actually
breaking down if someone says they're
depressed I actually want to know what
that means and where it fits and so a
couple of ways that I do that that
really helped me are first starting with
this as Nicole went over was it Emily
who's was Nicole this morning right if I
already forgotten thank you Emily I knew
it was Emily okay Emily was going over
the DSM criteria for borderline
personality disorder one of the ways we
look at it in dialectical behavior
therapy is categories of dysregulation
so that if you have a pervasive
dysfunction of emotion regulation you're
going to have interpersonal problems
you're not going to know who you are
and
your behaviors oops sorry behaviors
usually occur either because your dis
regulator you're attempting to regulate
and sometimes you can't think straight
oh my god that's true of any of us even
if we don't have borderline personality
certain emotions are aroused that's just
the way the brain works so my patients
and I will actually go through all these
categories and figure out what are we
exactly targeting here and whether
there's a med that helps it that could
help it or whether there's things that
may be prescribed to them that are
interfering does that make sense so for
example if we look at this recently MMK
was in for a pharmacotherapy session
just this past Monday and for years we
actually targeted this very severe stuff
years ago many suicide attempts a lot of
self-injury the dissociation really
interfered and etc now this week last
week she says to me and this is the
first time this has ever come out of her
mouth and we're standing in my office
and she's dissociating so I have her on
a balance board and I'm holding her
hands and making her balance as she's
laughing because she's dissociating so
we can't talk about the meds so she
stops associating and she looks at me
she goes okay I'm ready I really do want
to work with you guys on decreasing
dissociation so so right now I have
somebody who I looked at medications
regarding this and now she wants to look
at whether the meds can help with that
or not as well as what she's doing with
her primary therapist if even more so
what she's gonna be doing behaviorally
but I've got an eye now to what she and
I are going to be targeting a little bit
more closely alright the other thing
that I use with patients is so to do
that I I go over the symptoms that way
the other thing is the borderline
symptom checklist I don't have an
example here but it's a it's a really
handy way of going over with my patients
all the different nuances of what you
call borderline personality disorder and
we can pick things to do meds around and
then what I do with them is I'll have
patients come in with four weeks worth
of diary cards from their therapist
them or I'll have them fill out a
borderline symptom checklist at the
beginning of my pharmacotherapy
treatment with them and then every month
or two fill it out again and we'll
actually go over those things together
so this is the other piece of this I
want you to get the sense that I don't
just do this once I'm spending time with
them each time saying where are we
sitting we said we were gonna do the
meds for this reason let's actually see
what's happening with those does that
make sense all right so the other thing
that I do is and I'm actually going to
show you this this is one of the
handouts that was handed to you this
morning this is Adams diary card and so
again he was happy to use this I
actually both do his pharmacotherapy and
I'm his individual DBT therapist but I
wouldn't to make some points about what
we do with this in terms of the pharmaco
therapy so for example when it comes to
disorders of cognitive dysregulation
adam also has a head injury and he has
difficulty processing information so
that's something that we're always
working on as well as the fact that his
cognitive dysregulation can be intense
once he starts once it once he gets the
horse gets out of the barn he starts to
believe that everyone including me are
are spying on him that were actually
taping him he also has some terrible
PTSD that involved videos so he starts
to get into this almost flashback that
maybe we're doing what his perpetrator
did and he gets completely down the
chute I call it lose mine now you guys
aren't from Minnesota do you know what
luge is you know lose the loose sled
it's like blues mine okay and so Adam
has named that if you you'll probably
have to look on your thing he describes
that as full force rigid thoughts that's
his word for it because it's exactly
what happens it'll happen in front of me
it happens in situations that are really
hard really interfere with his life and
so we actually followed this in terms of
medications we may be adjusting or not
justic again I'm not gonna say what
we're doing for it but I just want to
say that that's what we look at you know
another thing that he gets is he's
extremely vulnerable to him
emotions his emotional vulnerability and
dysregulation just boom it just goes so
quick and again the the the head
injuries do not help he's got against
very severe frontal lobe dysfunction and
that was acquired unfortunately by
multiple suicide attempts ending up with
anoxia by taking opiate overdoses it's
very sad and he knows this you know so
so what he came up with for that is if
you look on your column here urges to
it's actually guns under sensations
it says boat overload for Adam he is he
can describe this so well you know two
people are talking about him something's
going on it's not an easy situation it's
stressful and he says he feels like he's
in a boat and people keep getting into
the boat it's a little it's a little
life raft you know little dinghy
and people keep getting into the boat
and before he knows that the boat is
gonna tip over they're in an ocean it's
a storm it's just terrible for and so
this is another way we can look at the
medications in terms of mood mood and
affect lability alright now part two
this is back to our hierarchy so now
what I've done is I've addressed with my
patients what symptoms are we managing
what are we actually what are these met
and it's very precise you're not just
throwing meds at people but it's this
kind of note and it's the real ethos of
it is us doing it together so now what I
want to look at is okay we know what
we're targeting with these meds or meds
that we've taken away how are you doing
how's your health in DBT we talked about
please skills these are the skills that
are related to self-management of health
related behaviors and of reducing your
vulnerability to being in a state of
emotion arousal without without being
able to control it getting plenty of
sleep taking care of your physical
illnesses unfortunately for my patients
I am really at a tertiary care sort of
Outer Mongolia role because I work for
DHS and it's very sad but many of my
patient nobody comes to me until
everybody else has given up on them and
they're usually in the committed system
it's it's a nightmare for these people
and so by the time they come to me they
have all these health-related
problems many of which are part of
having been in institutions where you
get no exercise and the food sucks all
the way to the side effects of the
medications so for example I have CeCe
someone I'm gonna talk to you about who
just called me last week she was so
excited I'll tell you what call me about
anyways I've treated her for quite a
while it's been over four years since
she had any drug she was a meth addict
it's been at least three and a half
years since she's had any aggression
self-injury and suicide attempts she's
now working she's got a permanent home
she's studying to be a peer support
specialist but she is horribly obese and
she's quite embarrassed about this not
to mention that some of the meds that
she was given added to that right so she
and I are spending a lot of time these
days working on helping her find ways to
exercise eat healthy and lose weight so
we'll actually assess what she's eaten
the week before and figure out together
where she can make changes and she was
so excited to call me another week she
goes she left a message she said you
can't believe it okay so when I went to
Walmart
instead of getting chips and all that I
got hummus like you like you brought to
me I gave her hummus one day and just
like oh this is really good I said like
no so I got hummus and carrot sticks and
then I got on the scale and I knew I had
gained weight but instead I'd lost seven
pounds and so another thing that we've
done in my sessions like with her is in
my pharmacotherapy session we've planned
for teaching her mindful eating as part
of the session so she'll come in with a
healthy lunch I'll have a healthy lunch
we inspect each other's food to see if
it's healthy and then I teach her how to
sit and mindfully eat so to me that is
absolutely part of pharmacotherapy did
you see because my job is to increase
capabilities and you are more capable if
you're healthier so are you following
kind of it's hard to know because I know
we're not talking to each other right
now so all right this you know CeCe is
another example she has terrible
obstructive sleep apnea so early on I
was ruthless in getting her to a sleep
study ruthless and her getting a CPAP
machine and then she and I and the group
home shoes in worked on we did
behavioral analysis of every time she
didn't use that freakin CPAP machine
until we
figured out what to do including getting
her back to the respiratory therapist
for a better way of sticking it on her
face she uses it every night now I mean
this is a woman again Tereus bipolar
disorder terrible PTSD substance
dependence and borderline personality
disorder which is much more not there
anymore and you know sticking that mask
on her face was a big deal we had to
really expose her to it and get her to
do it and I'll tell you it's made a huge
difference getting a good night's sleep
is like nobody's business if you have a
mood disorder
alright that's this is just to show you
the other side of this card if you
haven't seen them you've got them in
there I know it's hard to see these but
but I will actually when I have them
bring in like four weeks worth of cards
I'll glance down the skills and I'll be
particularly paying attention to these
please skills here and seeing how often
they're using those okay so finally
something that I actually don't get too
often is people not taking their meds
although m'kay is the master of
finagling as she says so we often work
on many sets and things like that but
the reason I put this in here about
standard cognitive behavior therapy is
this standard cognitive behavior therapy
is is part DBT is a cognitive behavior
therapy and so just because I'm doing
pharmacotherapy doesn't mean I'm not
always figuring out what is it that's
getting in the way and actually doing
what we call is a meta-analysis of kind
of a broad macro look at if you didn't
take you guys are like with Christine I
mean see see you know if you didn't use
your CPAP let's do a behavioral analysis
and what got in the way and we try to
look for patterns and then we come up
with solutions and so in these solutions
we figured out for her she had to expose
herself to the mask so she actually
started by wearing her CPAP mask on the
couch in the day for 30 minutes and then
it just took a couple times and she was
ready to go so you're still doing these
therapeutic interventions even though
it's in the service of increasing their
capabilities through pharmacotherapy you
know better living through chemistry
I'm all for that but I want it to be
actually better living
okay my the idea here for all of this is
this so you've got remember we started
out you've got all those parts you've
got everything you need in your junk
pile to have your life to be able to
drive out of hell and you have things
you don't need yet but you can't figure
out whether you have them or not unless
you dig through that pile and then some
of those parts you need and some of them
you don't I mean the idea here for me is
to build this little go-cart which I
that's what I'm doing with them and
that's what the two of us together want
to do and by the way YouTube says it's
only cost 15 dollars to make but it
really is all of this all of the
Energy's my patients and I do are get
you the hell out of hell and not just
get you out of hell but start to develop
this beautiful life you know it's like
these patients that I see that that no
longer have borderline personality sort
of I mean honest to god sometimes I feel
like I'm with these advanced spiritual
people I've got a couple that like one
of them I was one of them just the other
day Chris who's also a cardi she's an
advanced cardiac life support nurse
she's brilliant 40 years literally of
devastating depression interacting with
the borderline personality sort of she
she's been like amazing the last five
years and so what we're working on now
is sex because her life would be better
if she had a partner could have good sex
I mean come on come on ladies all right
let's be real here right sure no but
it's true I mean this is a
health-related thing and I couldn't
believe so so we've been trying to
figure out because she has on the
spectrum of libido she has a low libido
so I sent her out to watch sort of racy
movies that didn't do her any good so I
said well go let's talk she has a lot of
endocrine problems I said we'll go talk
to your primary care cuz maybe it's
these endocrine things do you know what
her primary care doctors sent her I mean
I shouldn't slam other doctors and she's
so forgiving she said you know I think
she was just not in a good mood that day
she said you're 61 what do you expect
and Chris is so good
she said you know she's been like this
before really invalidating it I totally
get it cuz sometimes she's busy and she
just doesn't think but Chris is driving
out of hell and she's got an appointment
with a friend of mine who's a human
sexuality expert to help us figure this
out cuz we're gonna get her not only out
of hell but really having the good life
she's gonna be on that go-kart maybe
she's gonna be on a Harley okay so let
me finish up with trying to tell you
about the five hundred and twenty four
pages in the treatment manual and again
some of you are DBT practitioners or you
or you get treated this way you know in
all of my sessions
I am weaving these three principles that
uphold the strategies and principles of
DBT is I want to be able to be in a
place of complete acceptance of where
you are right now I also though realize
that where you are is hell and you've
got to get out of it
so I've got to have techniques to help
you change and when we're butting heads
I have to step back into what we call a
dialectical worldview and step back into
this idea that when we're polarized and
I'm like this that there's truth on what
I'm saying there's truth on what you're
saying and how do we come to a synthesis
so I'll give you an example of kind of
going through some of these things and
in terms of the dialectics for example
even Adam the one who generously gave us
his diary card you know he his he can
butt heads like nobody's business and
then you add the frontal lobe just a
tragedy on to it it's like oh my god and
he and I have gone back and forth on how
to do this and we've come up with all
kinds of synthesis over the years for
example according to people in Minnesota
I speak fast do I speak fast here - okay
well let me tell you I grew up in
Ridgefield Connecticut I lived there
till I was 13 okay so thank you well I
apparently speak really fast in
Minnesota and Adams brain goes really
slow and we would have these like at the
end of a session where I couldn't get
him out the door his brain was like he
hadn't gotten anything I mean we were
going at it on the
and I had my limits of this is how much
time I had on the other his brain wasn't
processing so we came up with an idea
that is somewhat unusual for psycho
pharmacotherapy but also remember he's
on his individual therapists we actually
changed from an hour a week session to
an hour and a half his brain goes slower
is that isn't that beautiful
I mean he's absolutely right I only have
so much time and his brain goes slow
well then what the hell are we trying to
force ourselves into something because
that's what everyone's 50-minute hour
therefore you know and now keep in mind
that I mean thank God I'm in public
health I mean this is kind of terrible
but if he had insurance and I was in a
private office would be telling me I
couldn't do it ain't gonna happen to me
I'm trying to be perfect so that's the
dialectical part of this I was thinking
about these two things to give you an
example of and let me watch my time I've
got about a minute
this happened on Tuesday on Tuesdays I
go to a residential state-run inpatient
block chemical dependency again so if
you can imagine nobody gets to these
places unless a lot of crap has happened
so and I'm there I'm a consultant there
on Tuesdays and JJ who is has a severe
neurodevelopmental disorders terrible
meth addiction some sort of mood
disorder not otherwise specified that
seems to related to the
neurodevelopmental disorder and
borderline personality disorder and he
goes AWOL last week and ends up using
meth again okay so he comes we hear we
finally I get a call from his mom on
Tuesday she's in the car behind an
ambulance following him because thank
God he called
I mean his mom loves him dearly and
we've been working very closely with his
mom and her and him he's like 21 years
old so he's really pretty young and so
the acceptance part of this I wanted to
tell you about was this because it
struck me as I was thinking about this
this talk this week so we're sitting
here myself and JJ and first I go see
him and he's in the gym with his
counselor because he's so you know he's
just coming off the math he feels like
crap and he's you know and he's he's
frightened I get him out of the gym we
go into my office we get his mom on the
speakerphone we and the psychologist is
with me so the two of us are with him in
that room he's panicked he's crying
he feels like [ __ ] and we both grab his
hands I grab one hand and she grabs the
other and we just press on his palms and
I say to his mom we're holding his hands
right now she said oh thank god because
that's what I did in the ER and it
really calmed him down I said perfect
we're holding his hands you see how
that's just the way you are right now
okay
at the same time obviously he's in G's
and he feels like crap right now I've
got to get him out of that not just with
pharmacotherapy whatever else we can do
so so when we were in the gym before
this part where I got him in my office
he was crumped over like this I'm
running like this and I go I'm 53 years
old
you know and and as we start to run and
walk briskly together his breathing
regulates and he tells me the story of
how he relapsed so now I can do
behavioral analysis and I'm working on
changed you see how that goes together
and then dialectics involves things like
even what we call stylistics where you
balance your acceptance and your being
right there and being radically genuine
yourself with things like irreverence
and throwing people off balance because
when we get thrown off balance if you're
polarize if someone says something funny
or something that kind of piques your
curiosity your hippocampus opens it's
really cool right so we've been sitting
there holding his hand he's crying we're
working on trying to get him settled all
of a sudden he says I need to go to the
site hospital now psych hospitals for
him have been problematic and that
they've really reinforced suicidal
behavior because I think he'd get he
would start telling people he's gonna
kill himself and then they put him in
the hospital and so he would escalate
telling people's gonna kill himself then
he would actually try to kill himself
and they put in the hospital so we're
really trying to break that pattern and
so we're sitting there holding his hand
I gotta go to the psych hospital and I
look at him and I leaned close I said
I've got three colleagues I work very
closely at the psych hospital he goes oh
all right right so I'm gonna actually
stop there there's some other couple
slides but I think that we do want to
have time for a question and answer and
I can see Emily who promised I would do
that because I don't want to get off
schedule because there's a break at
tense and there's nothing worse than
people not getting a break on time
correct does it you know come on ten
minutes
who knows where you'll drive to about
ten minutes all right thank you very
much we're gonna ask if you have
questions to start passing them to the
aisles you'll see that they're
volunteers that will
pick them up if I'm direct them up here
we already have a couple of questions so
one of them though is asking about
medications how do you feel about
answering your question about
medications so the question is do you
have any recommendations on medications
on how to manage sleep and food dis
regulations other than stimulants they
just seem sleep and food dysregulation
he's that guy in the back is believe it
you mean I got to do this right okay
sorry sorry boy that's just so general
I'd have to know the patient mean here's
the issue if I have someone with
dysregulated eating or dysregulated
sleep we're doing behavioral analysis of
what that is and then I'm gonna drive
the medication towards what particularly
for them so I really would have to say I
couldn't give a generic recommendation
but it's it's more what I want to get
you this idea is that this idea of
understanding how to do behavioral
analysis will help you figure that out
okay but you can meet me in the back
afterwards and tell me what you really
mean well treatment interfering refers
to behaviors that interfere with you as
the clinician delivering treatment so
it's either things that you do that bug
the patient or it's things they do that
bug you so if someone was smoking in my
face in my office
it would probably bug me that being said
it is a health related problem and so I
for example see see is someone who I was
scared crapless I'm trying not to swear
that's right I'm on the East Coast it's
okay
I get in trouble for this allah charlie
don't you him that story of when you
said [ __ ] in minnesota that the only
place they've told you like the only
place you can credit it off yeah so
anyways see see for example has has
worked on giving up smoking and we
finally decided to let her do chant x
which of course can make people not see
even when you're not nuts to begin with
and bless her heart
we walked her through the nuts at night
by changing some of her meds at night to
help her with how it made her kind of
goofy and it's helped and she stopped
smoking now on the other hand i have
another patient came in with cigars this
is what gave me the idea to give my son
chicago because him and his dad came in
and they know there's a really good
cigar shop and they're pulling out these
cigars at our meeting and i'm like oh my
gosh magnin and all of a sudden i
realized that we could all be arrested
because of state property it is against
the law to have tobacco on it so that
would be therapy interfering if i like
this security guard had come in and we
were all arrested alright i think i
don't think this is what they expected
but if you can explain the difference
between para su dos para suicidal
behaviour and suicidal behavior okay so
in the field of research of how do you
call what behaviors it used to be that
para suicidal behaviors were any
self-injury without the intent to die
and suicidal behaviors were
self-injuring which the intent was to
die so it had to do with intent
probably more phenomenologically precise
and what is used more often now in the
literature is suicidal self-injurious
behavior and non-suicidal self injurious
behavior someone we have actually a
couple questions i'm going to try to
merge into one question synthesis
synthesis um we have some questions
asking about if patients can't tolerate
the medications or
with Polly farm prescription being so
widely common with VPD what are your
approaches that you use in those cases
to deal with patients that maybe don't
want Polly farm because they've had bad
experiences or that want to decrease the
number of meds that they're on because
they don't want all the side effects or
that simply can't tolerate the
medications that maybe are going to help
reduce the specific symptoms that
they're reporting yes okay so on the
other hand I'm like the anti Oakley
available polypharmacy and I know if I
have some psychiatry consult colleagues
here you might be aghast on the other
hand again this gets back to the
precision and the understanding symptoms
so it's not only understand the symptoms
of borderline personality sir but me and
the patient and I looking at the side
effects and deciding you know what are
the risks and benefits and there's
something in distress tolerance that we
use called pros and cons it's also a
commitment strategy it's very similar to
in motivational interviewing payoff
matrix so it's not uncommon for me in a
session to get I always have a
whiteboard is to get on and say okay I
really don't want to take this abilify
for example oh god I just said a minute
and Ripper's all okay so so we've
already looked over the symptoms we're
addressing as to why we might use this
so we'll write on the board will put use
aerosol pros and cons don't use air for
purpose all pros and cons and will
actually go through a matrix it's
actually a dialectical assessment of
using whatever the different medications
there are so again it just I'm totally
in favor of helping people have the most
bang for their buck with the least
amount of side effects but again it's
it's this precision of doing it of how I
go about is what I'm trying to get
across
so keep handing in the questions if you
have them if I don't ask them we do have
a panel discussion at the end of the day
where a lot of the questions that might
be relevant to multiple speakers will be
brought up then you have a question
about how do you handle clients who take
their medications wrong like maybe they
take too much at a time and then they
run out before they should or
intimate and you made it come on all
right okay all right it's not Emily what
is the deal here what what do you mean
that you sort of took the geodon with a
cracker but not a meal well I didn't
really feel like eating right then okay
all right
so Emily we've talked about this like a
zillion times you actually have a
problem where you don't often feel like
eating we've also talked about eating
being food because you need to wait 124
pounds and you get psychotic correct I'm
skipping ahead yes you do so you believe
me it's been beaten eyes your brain
Emily okay by the way all right so so
here's the deal
you I want you to take it twice a day
you know and I've told you that just
even a cracker isn't gonna be isn't
gonna get in your system so let's figure
this out are you when you get up are you
eating breakfast well if I have to take
it twice a day then that means I'm gonna
have to eat twice yeah I realize this is
a problem but just remember we're aiming
for 124 so there's no psychosis okay
we're rampage okay all right so there's
something that I know cuz you and Bev
have been working on the eating she said
that you've been tracking eating lunch
every day you've been having like yogurt
and a little salad yes that's right yeah
okay so why don't you just take it
during that time I think ice I could do
that yeah and then cuz you'd night you
know your husband Jeff and you I mean
the one thing we all love about you
having marry Jeff is you have to eat
dinner that's not I mean not that he's
isn't a great guy but we're all thrilled
that you guys sit down for dinner
together every night because I'm not
against if you if even if it's closer
together than morning and evening the
main thing is that you're getting it
with lunch which I know you're eating
because Bev will kill you if you're not
and Jeff and you have dinner together so
what do you thing about doing that I
think I'm a player I'm just I'm just
trying you see what I mean it's I don't
know what I would do with any of these
except assess the patient and together
at us figure it out yeah yeah otherwise
I just slap them around and you know
and I don't I don't I don't I promise
we've actually had a couple of questions
about this and we have a minute left so
we've had a couple questions about
people asking about ect as a
supplementation to the psycho farm that
you're prescribing they want ect
they're asking I think if you have
experience or if they can't tolerate the
medications do you recommend that it
depends on the patient's I have patients
right now on maintenance ect and I have
patients who I coach them in every way
shape and form to run like hell yeah so
it depends that's the famous DBT answer
it depends exactly so well thank you
very much dr. Witter holt